[Applaus]
[Musik]
ausnahmsweise lagen die prognostiker mal
richtig der französische präsident immer
nur in macau hat die zweite runde der
französischen präsidentschaftswahl nicht
nur gewonnen sondern auch seine
konkurrentin marie le pen abstand von 16
prozentpunkten ausgestochen etwa 58
prozent für makro und 42 prozent für le
pen beine vorsprung der sich gegenüber
den letzten präsidentschaftswahl es war
halb der tat damals betrug satte 32
prozentpunkte aber wir sprechen immer
noch von einem großen unterschied für
ein land in dem es nicht gerade üblich
ist wiedergewählt zu werden es ist das
erste mal seit 20 jahren dass ein
französischer präsident seine zweite
amtszeit antreten wird und es ist das
erste mal seit mehr als 50 jahren dass
ein präsident das politische leben
vollständig dominiert ohne mit einer
regierung unter premierminister aus
einer anderen von der
nationalversammlung gewählten partei
zusammenarbeiten zu müssen
dies ist noch beachtenswerte wenn man
bedenkt dass macros wiederwahl nach der
korona krise und inmitten einer riesigen
inflationsspirale stattfand überdies war
die zahl der nichtwähler enorm hoch und
was soll ich sagen wenn man etwas am
status quo ändern möchte bleibt man
normalerweise am wahltag nicht zu hause
kennt wäre den meisten daheim
gebliebenen dann doch wohl zuviel der
veränderung gewesen mit anderen worten
so sehr mag für die niedrige
wahlbeteiligung und das
zusammenschmelzen des abstandes zu le
pen kritisiert wurde unterm strich
können wir fast von einem neuen
sonnenkönig der französischen politik
sprechen er ist nicht der beliebteste
führer und er hat den ruf autoritär und
arrogant zu sein aber er hat die führung
in amt und im land fest in pont jahr das
merkwürdigste daran ist eben dass die
franzosen in gar nicht so gut leiden
können eine meinungsumfragen wird in die
gesagt regelmäßig vorgeworfen arrogant
autoritär und abgehoben zu sein na ja
manche sagen sich wohl einbildung ist
auch mit bildung aber ich bin mir sicher
dass fotos wie dieses nicht gerade
hilfreich sind
und nicht nur das wir können nicht
einmal sagen dass in der lage wäre mit
seinen politischen vorschlägen die
massen mitzunehmen in der ersten runde
unterstützen fast 60 prozent der
französischen wähler die kandidaten der
extremen rechten oder der extremen
linken und die nichtwählerquote von 28
prozentpunkten in der zweiten wahlrunde
ist ebenfalls die höchste in einem
halben jahrhundert
es ist klar dass makro keine
leidenschaft weckt aber warum hat der
mann der seine lehrerin und mutter
seiner schulfreundin ehelichte so einen
erfolg warum hatte die gegenkandidatin
die wiederum ihren vater politisch
ermordet hat keine chance gegen ihn
wohin steuert die französische politik
und was können wir in seiner neuen
zweiten amtszeit von frankreich erwarten
sind die franzosen psycho politisch in
einer oldie pal freude die amischen
dichotomie gefangen nun falls er keine
ahnung hat was ich da gerade von mir
gebe es aber trotzdem interessant klingt
den spitzkehren bauscher wir machen uns
auf in ein land in dem die politischen
uhren dann schön ticken
warum makro
[Musik]
der französische staatschef hat
frankreich mit einer harten hand geführt
als er 2010 an die macht kam weil weder
rechts noch links sondern versuchte ein
neues frankreich zu gestalten während
seiner ersten amtszeit gab es
augenblicke in dem seine präsidentschaft
kurz vor dem ende zu stehen schien doch
er kam immer wieder auf die beine wieder
und wieder da waren zb die aufstände der
geld besten die größten proteste seit
jahrzehnten oder auch die korona krise
bei der die franzosen anfangs zu den
größten entgegen gehörten heute sind 78
prozent der bevölkerung durchgeimpft ein
höherer prozentsatz als in deutschland
etwa eigentlich ein königreich oder den
usa vor allem hat er aber versucht
frankreich zu modernisieren und wände
über die modernisierung des gallischen
landes sprechen geht es vor allem um
seine wirtschaft
um euch eine vorstellung zu geben
frankreichs wirtschaft ist in den
letzten zehn jahren im schnitt um ein
prozent gewachsen und wenn der staat der
wirtschaft als ganzes ist das bip pro
kopf betrachten und ich denke ein bild
sagt mehr als tausend worte
in us dollar ausgedrückt sind die
franzosen seit mehr als 14 jahren dabei
an wohlstand verlieren aber selbst wenn
wir die auswirkungen von
wechselkursschwankungen
eliminieren ist das ergebnis nicht
besser im gesamten jahr 10 vor corona
stieg die wirtschaftsleistung
frankreichs und kaum sechs prozent das
ist eine viel schlechtere bilanz als die
den meisten industrieländern
mit anderen worten wie ihr seht liegt
die französische wirtschaft praktisch im
wachkoma und selbst bei der großzügigen
auslegung sind die zahlen des letzten
jahrzehnts mehr als enttäuschend wir
sprechen von einem defizit von mehr als
sechs prozent des bip einer
staatsverschuldung von mehr als 112 post
exorbitanten öffentlichen ausgaben von
nicht weniger als 55 prozent des bip und
praktisch keinem wachstum während der
letzten jahre selbst unter den größten
kraftanstrengungen und beim besten
willen ist es extrem schwierig
irgendeine statistik zu finden in der
die dinge für die kommission wirklich
gut laufen ein guter indikator könnte
die industrieproduktion sein dass sie
sich in den industrieländern auf einem
allzeithoch befindet und frankreich hat
traditionell ein staat
industrialisiertes land ist die frage
lautet also wie hat sich die
industrieproduktion in frankreich
entwickelt nun auch hier gilt ein bild
sagt mehr als tausend worte
um dieses problem anzugehen hat makro
anstrengungen unternommen die
wirtschafts- und regulieren und die
steuern zu senken bemühungen die vor der
wirtschaft sehr gut aufgenommen wurden
und ist zum beispiel ermöglicht haben
dass die arbeitslosigkeit auf sieben
prozent gesunken ist den niedrigsten
stand seit 2008 zu seiner erfolgen
gehört auch die tatsache dass sich
frankreich von den größten europäischen
volkswirtschaften am schnellsten von der
krise erholt wie dieser grafik sehen
kannst war frankreich die einzige große
volkswirtschaft die sich bis ende 2021
auf das niveau vor den lockt aus erholt
hatte
eine seiner ersten maßnahmen nach seiner
vereidigung als präsident im jahr 2017
war die abschaffung der vermögenssteuer
unter seinen größten erfolgen werden in
der regel auch die senkung der
körperschaftssteuer also unternehmen
steuern um 8 punkte und die
arbeitsmarktreform vorgelogen die das
einstellung entlassen von arbeitnehmern
erleichtert vielleicht ist es deshalb
nicht überraschend dass dort umfragen
fast acht von zehn führungskräften aus
der französischen wirtschaft firma
gestimmt haben aber auf jeden fall reden
wir über nur kleine veränderungen
zumindest viel kleiner als das was die
französische wirtschaft wirklich
bräuchte natürlich sind sie besser als
gar nichts und für eine übergangszeit
haben sie auch funktioniert und genau
diese linie hat makro auch jetzt wieder
eingeschlagen er hat unter anderem
versprochen die produktions steuern für
unternehmen und selbständig um 7
milliarden euro zu senken die
erbschaftsteuer zu reduzieren und bis
2027 ein defizit von 3 prozent des bip
zu erreichen mit anderen worten diskrete
anpassungen und fünf weitere jahre
bilder ausgaben orgien denn man hat ja
eben nicht
[Musik]
allein seit beginn des krieges in der
ukraine hat die französische regierung
22 milliarden euro ausgegeben um
verbraucher und unternehmen für die
preiserhöhungen bei gas strom und benzin
zu entschädigen das alles kommt aus den
öffentlichen kassen schätzungen zufolge
werden makros wohltaten das französische
staatsdefizit um 74 milliarden euro pro
jahr erhöhen anstatt sein wovon endlich
zu stoppen und das auch nur dann wenn er
seine versprechungen einhält und ist
nicht noch dollar kommt nun zu erwarten
ist es nicht denn wenn makro während
seiner ersten amtszeit etwas gelernt hat
war es dass man außenpolitisch nur
forsch und ausdauernd genug auftreten
muss bis berlin einknickt und alle
rechnungen bezahlt daher ist es schon
jetzt mehr als klar dass er eine noch
aggressivere internationale rolle
anstrebt als bisher
makro will dass paris in brüssel das
sagen hat in den letzten monaten haben
wir zum beispiel gesehen wie er in der
ukraine krieg ist eine sehr wichtige
rolle spielen wollte auch wenn das nicht
besonders gut geklappt hat da gute etwas
über alte schuljunge emanuel dachte doch
allen ernstes er könne wladimir putin
durch stundenlange telefonate zur
vernunft bringen wahrscheinlich blickte
er während der für ihn
nervenaufreibenden gespräche ständig in
die augen seiner frau während in der
kreml herrscher genüsslich träumte und
so wertvolle zeit schinden konnte doch
makro wollte dadurch nicht nur noch vor
der wahl punkte sammeln und sein profil
als der mondäne und professionelle
staatsmann schärfen heißt ja immer gerne
auftritt wie gesagt das alles sind nur
auftritte denn alles was übrig blieb war
das bild eines amateurhaften naiv links
gut gemeint ist eben nur sehr selten gut
gemacht und oft das genaue gegenteil vor
allem wenn dabei das gewusst wie
vollkommen erzählt und man mit dem guten
zweck eigentlich noch einen bösen
verbinden denn in wahrheit ging es mag
ja sein tut den telefonaten noch um was
ganz anderes rache wohlgemerkt nicht
amputieren sondern an seinen eigenen
verbündeten ich werde euch gleich
verraten was ich damit meinen
schließlich gegen nämlich auch dieses
vorhaben mal groß total in die hose
weswegen die französische regierung
europa bei der einführung eines
öl-embargos gegen russland natürlich
unterstützen wird die ukraine krise hat
uns also wieder einmal den unbeständigen
war und auch verachtung vollen charakter
max vor augen geführt es handelt sich
vielleicht um die schlimmste seite des
französischen präsidenten den ewigen
pariser opportunismus
[Musik]
der opportunistische aspekt des
französischen präsidenten
makro wollte zuerst die spannungen an
der ukrainischen grenze und dann den
krieg nutzen um sich von boston zu
distanzieren eine eigene politische
position zu beanspruchen mit putin zu
verhandeln und sich damit für den aufbau
zu rechnen den er mit autos erlitten hat
damals handelte es sich bereits um eine
der schwärzesten stunden des
französischen außen und bündnispolitik
paris bekam die quittung für seinen
opportunistisches notieren als die
australische regierung einen
millionenschweren deal mit der
französischen militär industrie
stornierte um einen besseren mit den
vereinigten staaten und die vereinigten
königreich abzuschließen und das war
nicht das schlimmste das schlimmste war
dass paris davon im grunde erst aus der
presse erfahren hat ein weiterer beweis
dafür wie wenig vom einfluss der
cornerstone übrig geblieben ist mit der
jetzigen politik ist ist auf dem besten
wege zusammen mit deutschland im orkus
der geopolitik zu verschwinden ihr wisst
dass wir hier bei visual politik starke
verfechter des europäischen gedankens
oder europäischen einheit sind aber
angesichts dessen was diese beiden
länder vorführen drückt der exit immer
mehr wie ein freak city
[Musik]
was ich damit meine nun den exit
frankreichs und deutschlands aus dem
kreis der weltmächte die noch was zu
melden haben sie verlieren immer mehr
den anschluss das eine weil es führen
will aber nicht kann und das andere weil
es irgendwie auch führen will aber nicht
die eier hat es zuzugeben und es
außerdem auch nicht kann gut im
gegensatz zum deutschen kanzler dennoch
mehr opportunismus und wankelmut immer
spricht es der französische präsident
die nächsten wochen aus die europäer
müssen aufhören naiv zu sein wir müssen
reagieren und zeigen dass wir die kraft
um die fähigkeit haben uns zu
verteidigen und ausgerechnet als es in
der ukraine heiß her ging dachte
mackrodt dies sei die perfekte
gelegenheit der us-regierung einen tritt
in den hintern zu verpassen deshalb hat
ein europaparlament selbst die folgende
erklärung abgegeben es ist gut wenn sich
die europäer und die vereinigten staaten
abstimmen aber die europäer müssen ihren
eigenen dialog führen kein gemeinsamer
standpunkt keine steigung der nato oder
ähnliches die europäische union muss
drin alleingang mit putin verhandeln und
als typischer sonnenkönig verschnitt
dachte makro natürlich ich bin ja selber
natürlich ist er damit voll gegen die
wand gefahren makro passt wirklich
niemanden überzeugt während paris zur
europäischen einheit auf rechts blickten
warschau italien riga vilnius prag
stockholm helsinki kopenhagen bratislava
praktisch alle europäischen hauptstädte
nach washington für sie war klar die
nato war der bestmögliche schutz in den
augenblick der einzig mögliche schutz
und zu allem überfluss firma kropp kam
es dann doch zur invasion russlands und
es wurde immer klarer dass eine
militärische antwort die einzig
realistische und machbare war die nato
gewann mit einem erdrutschsieg gegen max
sein plan flog zum fenster hinaus
[Musik]
und jetzt ratet mal was er dann tat
blitzschnell vollzog er eine seiner
klassischen 180 grad wenden eine kuss
umkehr die in gewisser weise auch
während seines wahlkampfs für die zweite
runde eine führende rolle gespielt hat
als er einige linke position übernommen
hat wie die verlangsamung der erhöhung
des rentenalters oder die hinwendung zu
den grünen dabei handelt es sich um das
genaue gegenteil dessen was seine eigene
wirtschaftsagenda aus sagt
verbessert wichtige rentenreform um die
linke zu umwerben über das abstruse
französische rentensystem haben wir
sogar ein eigenes video gemacht dass ich
euch verlinken werde aber offensichtlich
ist frankreich eben frankreich und wir
würden es nicht für seine eigene natur
verantwortlich machen wenn es denn seine
eigenen rechnungen auch selbst bezahlen
würde und das problem ist dass all diese
fragen auch die großen
unzulänglichkeiten des französischen
präsidenten widerspiegeln marco hat dazu
beigetragen und frankreich zu verbessern
aber er hat nicht den radikalen wandel
herbeigeführt den er versprochen hatte
und erscheint auch nicht dazu bereit zu
sein dies in zukunft zu tun mag aussieht
bedeutet kontinuität in der
wirtschaftspolitik und auch in der
aussenpolitik und ich spreche nicht nur
von marine le pen die wahrheit ist dass
wir feststellen müssen dass die gesamte
französische politik total ist abseits
abgedriftet ist wohl selbst louis de
funes gendarmen truppe gegen die
traurige pariser gare de wie eine elite
einheit wirkt setzt euch jetzt lieber
gut hin
[Musik]
politik der extreme
schaut euch bitte mal das folgende
statement an sobald der
russisch-ukrainische krieg beendet und
durch einen friedensvertrag geregelt ist
werde ich mich für die umsetzung einer
strategischen annäherung zwischen der
nato und russland einsetzen das liegt im
interesse frankreichs und europas sowie
der vereinigten staaten eine aussage wie
noch viel besser zu verstehen ist wenn
wir diese andere verheißungen betracht
ziehen lücken verspricht frankreich aus
dem nato-bündnis kommando zurück zu
ziehen wenn sie die präsidentschafts
wahlen gewinnt le pen sieht in ihrem
bizarren paralleluniversum frankreich
nach wie vor als eine glorreiche
supermacht eine supermacht die einfach
nur ihren platz in der welt wieder
zurückerobern muss und um das zu
erreichen hat sie keinen besseren plan
als sich gegen die nato und die
europäische union aufzulehnen eine
protektionistische politik
voranzutreiben sich moskau anzunähern
und das land auch auf ein
wirtschaftliches und finanzpolitisches
himmelfahrts kommando zu schicken denn
le pen hat nicht nur große
steuersenkungen versprochen sondern auch
gleichzeitig gigantische
ausgabensteigerungen und was soll ich
sagen das ist normalerweise keine gute
kombination
es riecht er nach wirklich platten
populismus als nach irgendetwas anderem
vor allem nicht nach gewusst wie
beispiel gefällig le pen sagt sie wolle
die inflation bekämpfen indem sie den
internationalen handel bestraft und
jeder steuer senkt das die nachfrage der
haushalte noch mehr ankurbeln würde und
damit auch die preise wie bitte um euch
eine vorstellung davon zu geben le pens
versprechen würden ein zusätzliches der
fläche von 100 milliarden euro
verursachen so dass das französische
haushaltsloch auf über 250 milliarden
euro pro jahr explodieren würde und ihr
wisst dass ein französisches
haushaltsloch spätestens seit merkels
einknicken beim thema euro-bonds alles
andere als eine rein französisches
problem ist japan ist wahrlich eine
schlaue frau frankreich wieder zur
supermacht machen und den deutschen
steuerzahler dafür lächeln lassen
unter den vorschlägen bitten sich auch
dinge wie die wiedereinführung der
vermögenssteuer die verstaatlichung des
autobahnnetzes die senkung des
rentenalters auf 60 jahre und
vergünstigte kredite von bis zu 100.000
euro an familien den mindestens drei
kinder haben nun ja der letzte vorschlag
klingt gar nicht mal so schlecht europa
braucht eine bessere demografie das ist
klar aber bei näherer betrachtung würde
auch das ziemlich nach hinten losgehen
denn die frage ist ob dieses geld
kinderreiche familien in frankreich auch
anspornen würde ihre kinder zu bilden zu
emanzipieren und in die moderne
produktive gemeinschaft zu integrieren
in dieser hinsicht hat sogar marco die
besseren konzepte vorzuweisen denn in
frankreich kommt pro frau heute schon
mehr kinder zur welt als im rest europas
bei ihren eltern handelt es sich jedoch
meist und bildungsferne moslems mit der
rückständigen ansichten dass die zukunft
wird lebensweise ihrer kinder angeht
konflikte sind da vorprogrammiert und
auch einen geldregen für diese familien
wird diese nicht nachhaltig lösen können
ihr seht also man braucht keinen nazi
holzhammer um le pen zu entzaubern
überhaupt macht es keinen sinn hier
irgendwie rechts gegen links aus zu
spielen oder sich auch nur an diesen
konzepten zur einordnung der politik le
pens die auch makros zu orientieren im
18 jahrhundert gab frankreich der welt
die konzepte der politischen linken und
rechten und heute wird es einen neuen
übergang der politischen lager an diesen
beschreibt der analyst john woodman als
nationalisten gegen internationalisten
das heißt eine spaltung zwischen denen
die die globalisierung fürchten und
denen die sie als chance begreifen le
pen selbst sagte
es gibt nicht mehr links oder rechts die
ware spaltung besteht zwischen den
patrioten und den global ist auch wenn
dies eine zu starke vereinfachung des
politischen spektrums es trotz des
wahlergebnisses ist die extreme rechte
von le pen & co stärker denn je in der
tat lag sie bei den jugendlichen unter
arbeiterklasse vorn sie könnte also
durchaus die zukunft frankreichs
darstellen nationalismus euro skepsis
und die ablehnung von einwanderung
gewinnen immer mehr anhänger
[Musik]
aber bei der linken sieht ist nicht viel
anders aus die tatsache dass der
anführer des linken blocks ein so
radikaler kandidat wie milo ist mit
nicht gerade vertrauen die französische
gesellschaft scheint nicht nur zunehmend
gespalten und polarisiert zu sein
sondern immer weiter an die rente
abzudriften und wenn sich die lage in
frankreich weiter verschlechtert könnte
das ergebnis bald ganz anders aussehen
in der ersten oder dieser wahlen blieben
der historischen linken mittel kaum 2
prozent der stimmen und die rechte mitte
erreichte nicht einmal magere 5 prozent
das politische spektrum war also fast
vollständig zwischen macros mitte und
den extremen gespalten makros größte
herausforderung wird es sein ein gefühl
des zusammenhalts in einem extrem
zersplittert ein land zu schaffen aber
zumindest für den augenblick gibt es
fünf weitere jahre der kontinuität eine
kontinuität des opportunismus der
wankelmut oder 180 grad wenden ein sich
durchwursteln egal mit welchen dreckigen
mitteln und die alternative sehe noch
viel dreckiger aus
[Musik]
genau aus diesem grund wurde die
wiederwahl des französischen präsidenten
von fast allen internationalen
führungspersönlichkeiten mit lautem
jubel begrüßt von beiden über scholz
unser lenski selbst bis hin zur
präsidentin der europäischen kommission
ursula von der leyen glückwunsch an
emanuel war zu seiner wiederwahl
frankreich ist unser ältester
verbündeter und ein wichtiger partner
bei der bewältigung globaler
herausforderungen ich freue mich auf
unsere weitere enge zusammenarbeit auch
bei der unterstützung der ukraine der
verteidigung der demokratie und der
bekämpfung des klimawandels jetzt
braucht sich eine neue schlacht zusammen
die so genannte dritte runde makros
partei muss die wahlen zur
nationalversammlung im juni gewinnen
damit der präsident nach eigenem
gutdünken regieren kann und was soll ich
sagen auch wenn ich jetzt resigniert
klinge angesichts dessen was wir gesehen
haben wollen wir hoffen dass er erfolg
hat marco erweist sich zwar nicht als
revolutionärer präsident aber zumindest
hat er es geschafft das verrostete ruder
der französischen politik näher als
seine vorgänger herumzureißen er ist nun
mal das geringste übel trotzdem es wird
nicht genug sein und unter all den
alternativen scheint es nur alte formeln
zu geben von echter innovation und
zukunftsweisender änderungen keine spur
veränderungen von denen frankreich viele
bräuchte sehr viele in der wirtschaft
bei der sozial- und rentenpolitik der
sicherheits- und außenpolitik und so
weiter und so fort
überraschend war auf jeden fall das
ergebnis der wahl in den französischen
überseegebieten es unterscheidet sich
diametral von dem in der hauptstadt denn
je weiter ein ort von paris entfernt
liegt desto besser schnitt marine le pen
ab das galt sowohl im mutterland aber
vor allem für orte die ihre union wurde
luke französisch guyana und martin diese
hat sie bereits gewonnen einige sogar
mit großem vorsprung was also geht in
frankreich übersee departements genau
vor sich warum ticken die uhren dort
nochmals ganz anders als auf den
europäischen kontinent
das liebe visual politik fans werden wir
euch in einem der nächsten videos hier
auf unserem kanal zeigen vergesst also
bis nicht den kanal zu abonnieren und
ganz wichtig auch das glöckchen für die
benachrichtigung zu aktivieren der abo
status wird vom youtube algorithmus
mittlerweile weitgehend ignoriert das
was früher das abo war ist heute also
eher das glöckchen kontrolliert also
bitte nochmal das glöckchen auch wenn
ihr schon ein abo habt nur dann verpasst
ihr keine folge so und nun dürft ihr
euch in den kommentaren über frankreich
und makro auslassen was denkt ihr über
die ergi bis der französischen wahlen
was erwartet ihr von seiner zweiten
amtszeit glaubt ihr dass frankreich es
schaffen wird einen erfolgskurs
einzuschlagen und vor allem was würde
wohl sigmund freud über emanuele makro
und marine le pen sagen ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat falls ja
geht uns bitte einen leid und teils mit
euren freunden natürlich von 1000
jederzeit über eine spende von euch mit
der er uns helfen dieses projekte
weiterzuführen in paper link dazu findet
ihr in der beschreibung unter dem video
was gut und bis bald
[Musik]